an increasingly unhinged Jordan Peterson  publishing a series of trash tweets to  Twitter remember that after he flipped  out on me on Twitter a little while ago  he quit Twitter but he's returned  multiple times he retweets a video of a  flood and says oh look video from a  flood somewhere in the world give me all  the power now he retweets The Babylon  bee joking about Elmo dying of  myocarditis from the covet vaccine  saying and not a moment too soon I've  always detested that whiny infantilized  puppet and lastly retweeting Elon Musk  about pronouns saying compelled speech  not acceptable gain of function research  Millions dead Millions not hundreds of  millions yet Peterson unhinged once  again